let's talk about how to shrink thyroid
nodules
naturally now before i get into it i
want to make a disclaimer this is not
meant to replace your medical care check
with your doctor before taking any of
this advice this information is just to
give you more data so when you do your
evaluation of what to do you have both
sides you have the medical side and you
have the alternative side unfortunately
a lot of the alternative advice is
buried on google and it's very difficult
to find so that being said let's first
talk about how to do a self thyroid
examination now for this little exam
you're going to need a mirror
and a glass of water okay so the first
thing you want to do is identify where
the thyroid is so if i take my finger
and come down my neck right here this
little bump right here
that's the atom's apple it's actually
called the thyroid cartilage even though
the thyroid is not in that area it's
lower okay now if i take my finger and
keep coming down a little bit more
i'll go right into a little indentation
right here
okay now from this point down through
here
i'm going to be feeling these little
rings
of the trachea they're little pieces of
cartilage
and you can feel them as little bumps
right here now if we go downward we're
gonna feel two little bumps okay that's
two of the little rings we're gonna get
to the thyroid so if you go down two
and just put your finger right there and
then also right through here at the
bottom of where your
collarbone joins
that's where the thyroid is it's right
here and it's like a butterfly you have
these little wings with a little center
piece that right in the center okay so
the thyroid is right through here and if
you put your fingers on it okay and you
swallow
you drink water and look into the mirror
it'll raise up a little bit as you drink
water what you're looking for when
you're swallowing
is you're looking for
a little bump or a little lump or
protrusion
that sticks out
you're also feeling the symmetry between
the left side and the right side okay if
there's an enlargement on one side
versus the other that is abnormal what
you should feel is an equal amount on
both sides and you should not feel any
lump
bump or protrusion
if you do you could have either a nodule
or some type of an enlargement now the
first thing you need to know is that
these nodules are very very common
extremely common in young adults and
children and 50
of people over the age of 40 have them
and they can come and go
and 95 of them are benign so
only a very small percent are cancer
related if you went to a doctor they
would probably do a blood test
and an ultrasound test and they would
look at the thyroid hormones they would
also look at antibodies because
90 percent
of hypothyroid
conditions are hashimoto's that's an
autoimmune condition where there's
inflammation and in the condition
hashimoto's thyroiditis
there's this little itis which means
inflammation and so you can see more
nodules in hashimoto's now i've done a
lot of videos on hypothyroid conditions
and the symptoms and what to do
when we discuss hashimoto's we're really
talking about an autoimmune condition
more than a thyroid condition itself and
what triggers hashimoto's is your immune
system going out of whack more than
anything else that can come from
severe stress or trauma where stress or
shock like for example let's say you
lost a loved one can literally put your
immune system into a state where you're
susceptible to getting all sorts of
problems especially autoimmune but let's
go through the six things that can
contribute to thyroid nodules the first
thing
that i would do is i would eliminate all
dairy to see if your thyroid nodule
disappears because dairy has a lot of
different hormones and it can stimulate
the growth of your thyroid i mean if you
think about milk in general
milk is created to grow
animals okay like like in calves like in
sheep babies humans and animals so milk
has a lot of different growth hormones
and so if you're consuming milk that can
be a contributing factor so just by
avoiding dairy you may find these
nodules disappear the second thing is
gluten now if you've been watching my
channel you're probably not consuming
gluten but for those of you that are new
gluten is in grains it's a protein in
grains and it is majorly associated with
hashimoto's without getting into the
details there's actually a similarity or
a crossover
with the genetics of gluten and your
thyroid in other words if you consume
gluten
your body is going to identify that
dietary gluten
as an external invader a pathogen and
start developing antibodies and it can
actually then cross over and now you
have antibodies to not just attack
gluten but your own thyroid but at this
point i don't want to get into too many
details on that i'll put that link down
in the description but you may find that
these nodules completely disappear just
by avoiding gluten now i'm going to
recommend going on the ketogenic diet
because there's some additional data
that insulin resistance okay which
occurs when you consume a lot of carbs
predisposes you to developing nodules on
the thyroid gland and the combination of
both keto and intermittent fasting can
greatly help you in reducing these
nodules simply because of the
anti-inflammatory effect now as a side
note vitamin d is really beneficial for
hashimoto's especially when you're
taking about 30 or 40 000 international
units of vitamin d but i have not found
any type of causation between low
vitamin d and thyroid nodules but i will
say if you have autoimmune diseases
you're going to be deficient in vitamin
d so vitamin d can help you all right
number three selenium deficiencies
low selenium is associated with thyroid
nodules so that's definitely a mineral
that i would recommend taking you can
get selenium in brazil nuts
just one brazil nut can give you a whole
day
requirement of selenium selenium is also
in fish like tuna sardines salmon and
other types of fish selenium is actually
really good to counter mercury in the
fish as well selenium is also in organ
meats
as well as in meats in general and eggs
now a lot of people think that
you should take iodine if you have a
nodule and they may or may not be
correct with that because
if you take excessive amounts of iodine
you can actually create nodules so
iodine may help you
if you have a deficiency but if you're
already taking a lot of sea kelp for
example i wouldn't recommend taking more
c-califor iodine because that could be
causing it so here's my viewpoint with
iodine
if you're already taking a lot of c-cap
or iodine and you have these nodules
then you need to reduce that if you
haven't been taking c-calp or iodine i
think a little bit of sea kelp might
help you in reducing the size of the
nodules and the cool thing about sea
calp is it has selenium as well as
iodine and the next mineral i'm going to
talk about which is zinc
a zinc deficiency can increase your
susceptibility to getting these nodules
now where do you get zinc well it's in
red meat it's in shellfish and oysters
and it's in a lot of other foods as well
if you decide to take a supplement for
selenium or zinc i'll put the values
down below of what i recommend all right
number five estrogen dominance if you
have too much estrogen because the
thyroid has receptors for estrogen
that can cause nodules this is why women
who are estrogen dominant many times
will be more susceptible to getting
these nodules especially when they get
pregnant or they're taking birth control
pills or when they're taking some type
of estrogen as in hormone replacement
therapy so if that's your situation
get with your doctor uh maybe you could
come up with some other form of birth
control pill or
some other natural
hormone replacement therapy because
estrogen does affect the thyroid very
greatly and there's also a lot of
natural remedies to help lower estrogen
i will put that link down below too all
right number six there's an interesting
study which i'll include
that talks about a combination of using
turmeric which is very anti-inflammatory
spirulinum as well as boswella so a
combination of these three things showed
significant reduction in thyroid nodules
you can read the research down below but
i wanted to give you
some strategies in some simple things
that you can do
using natural remedies now if you have
not seen my other thyroid videos i put a
good one up right here check it out